what do you call yourself first name
Council last name geeks middle name of
[Music]
so I'm back from vacation and while I
was on vacation San Diego comic-con
happened now my original plan had been
to do a video you know do individual
videos covering some of the trailers
that came out that I really wanted to
talk about and then to do kind of a
summary about all the other news
snippets that weren't those trailers
that I'm scrapping I'm still gonna talk
about trailers I'm god there's rip well
there's four I'm gonna talk about you're
getting three videos today this one
later on you'll get my thoughts on the
titans trailer and then finally the
Aquaman trailer but first oh wait I mean
the big one that people are expecting
for me the Doctor Who trailer that's on
Sunday because that's what I normally
tactical Doctor Who stuff and I'm not
doing four videos in a day three is
enough so we're gonna start with this
one for glass I haven't talked about mmm
night Shyamalan's films and my feelings
on them on this channel before at all I
don't think and I was I was there Ground
Zero when The Sixth Sense hit I was
working in a movie theater when I hit I
got to see how the impact of that film
reverberating through a crowd so it was
it was an impressive thing to see
unbreakable
I think certainly at the time for a long
time was probably my own favorite movie
of his it it's not that it hasn't held
up it's that a lot of what it did that
was really innovative at the time no
longer is so it's more a case of the
rest of pop culture moviemaking has
caught up to it and so it's not as
unique as it used to be and honestly its
uniqueness was a big part of the promise
of unbreakable now I have seen split
which how cool is that that that was
like secret
Oh sequel tie-in like that that is how I
wish we could get more sort of
franchises built this completely sneaky
way and I don't want to knock you know
DC and Marvel for making the big
announcements and all that but I mean
how cool was it to suddenly realize holy
crap these things are interconnected and
then to realize we're gonna get a film
tying everything together and I'm just
gonna throw this out there as well if
we're talking about folks from Shyamalan
films who you know appear to have
extraordinary abilities that would be
questioned by a psychiatrist
um the boy from The Sixth Sense Haley
Joel Osment is acting again in
live-action I'm just saying I wouldn't
be shocked if he shows up in any case so
split before I get into glass
I did see split split was really good
now I haven't seen every Shyamalan film
I haven't seen The Last Airbender I
haven't seen after oath so I haven't
seen eye candy the visit I haven't seen
and that's more I heard it was decent
but I don't really like found footage I
get motion sick from it so I I haven't
seen a lot of his output recently I did
I did see him go off the cliff though
you know because I saw the village and I
saw I saw lady in the water which I
liked a lot better than most people I
know but I still can't really defend it
so it was really nice to see split and
see the man back on his game with a high
concept done with a level of borderline
pretension that just sort of classes up
the joint and makes it less exploitative
than that sort of premise normally would
be and JM was such a vehicle for James
McAvoy as a performer it was phenomenal
so I really enjoyed the heck on a split
and I thought it's it's twist at the end
even before the reveal of you know
connected universe stuff was pretty neat
in terms of how the survivor girl
survived and
why she did I found that to be
interesting so glass I love just about
everything about this trailer I love the
look I love the vibe I love these actors
the the thing with Shyamalan he really
does need to be paired with the right
actress because not everyone can take
his words and make them work he's a bit
like George Lucas in that way because
like you compare say you know the
original Star Wars film with the
prequels and you can see the actors most
of them struggling to work with the with
this script in this dialogue in the
prequels whereas he really kind of
lucked out in that original Star Wars
film because Harrison Ford Mark Hamill
and Carrie Fisher could all make that
stuff work whereas Hayden Christensen
Natalie Portman yeah and a lot of the
other actors in the prequels that kind
of couldn't so I think with Shyamalan
it's a similar thing be and and it's not
a it's not a mark of the quality of the
actors involved because there are some
very good actors who still can't wrap
their Atlas oh I like I remember I
remember watching the the village and
Sigourney Weaver God every line she
spoke I felt like just behind her eyes
she was silently screaming for the love
of God give me direction I don't know
how old a work with this dialogue that's
what it felt like every time she says I
mean that wife that woman never gives a
bad performance she's amazing in
everything but oh my gosh I could felt
like I was watching an actor flounder
but Bruce Willis can work with Shyamalan
Samuel Jackson can work with Shyamalan
James McAvoy can work with Shyamalan so
the three of these guys together and
then you know these are actors that can
work with Shyamalan and work with his
word so that's a good sign right off the
bat I love the visual styling is it over
what hell yeah but Shyamalan has best
tends to be overrun have you seen the
man's movies so I'm loving all that I
love Sarah Paulsen I I've discovered her
as an actress on American Horror Story
so I'm loving that
I'm loving this whole sort of initial
setup of trying to hell
is these men and then that real as that
were you know maybe a realization for
the audience of you know maybe putting
mr. glass in the same room is as the guy
who believes himself to be the Beast
maybe that was a bad idea and you know
with what we saw of James McAvoy's
character characters really were
physically capable of in split I think
him taking on David Dunn from
unbreakable that makes a lot of sense
and having it happen in a world that
doesn't believe that these people are
what they are is an interesting twist
because what we usually get in in any
sort of superhero thing that is ongoing
if you know we'll get things like Batman
daredevil where it's really just a guy
who's you know really skilled at what he
does but superhero I mean I know
daredevil a little bit but like
clear-cut superpowers not so much so in
those cases like people might be you
know somewhat that I am but whenever
you've got something like clear
superpowers like done has like whatever
name you want to use for all the
characters that James McAvoy plays have
usually what then happens in those
worlds when you do that narrative is the
world is now changed because we know
these people exist so to continue to
have their existence be denied even
though we as the audience will know that
it's all real is kind of interesting
because it allows it to remain in the
shadows in the background in the
underground when normally you would
think it would be more out and open by a
third film in the trilogy effectively
and so I find that really interesting
I love the Menace that we're getting
from well from Samuel Jackson especially
but also you know some of the
performances from James Mack for God so
looking for there was a shot of him and
split where he changed character in
camera and everything changed the
posture the cadence the tone of the
voice the way he works his way through
sentences absolutely everything you so
eat and even before you open his mouth
just his posture changing yeah
felt like you in this one shot you
watched the one character exit and
another one enter and it was awesome I'm
so looking forward to him kid getting
back into this character again and I and
the and the survivor girl from split is
back as well which I will be very
curious how that would because she was
quite good some of the other girls in
that movie were a little but she was
good she was solid um I'm just yeah I
can't remember the last time I could say
that I was genuinely excited to see a
Shyamalan film I'm often curious
curiosity morbid curiosity led me to
eventually seek out the happening
who but I'm rarely excited I'm excited
by this which may inevitably lead to
disappointment but right now I think I'm
just gonna watch the trailer again and
just smile so that's it for this one
later today I'll have it I'll have my
thoughts out on the Titans trailer and
also the Aquaman trailer and then
tomorrow
tune in for me to talk about the Doctor
Who trailer I know there's other stuff
besides the trailer to talk about those
will be in separate videos at later
dates I'm really trying not to do these
pile ups of multiple videos in a day but
if I don't do this sort of three video
dump on on this day then I'm just gonna
be backed up for weeks so that's what
happens so trailer for glass what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are jumps laying down in the comments
let's talk about there's all this stuff
to do you know what it is patreon is a
big one but you know what I've got links
for a bunch of other stuff that's
related to me it's all down in the
description take a look if you care and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]